[Musica]
voglio farvi una confessione Ma prima
vorrei che voi la facciate a me alzi la
mano che ha mai pensato che la propria
timidezza potesse essere uno tra i più
grandi ostacoli nel raggiungimento di
propri obiettivi
bene
tocca a me
chi mi conosce sa benissimo che non sono
un ottimo comunicatore Anzi raramente
comunico a scuola sono sempre stato
considerato quello silenzioso della
classe e spesso e volentieri i
professori si congratulavano di questa
cosa con i miei genitori quasi come
fosse un atto di rispetto ed educazione
nei confronti degli altri
ma nonostante ciò Nonostante questa mia
difficoltà nel comunicare oggi mi trovo
qui a parlare di fronte decisamente più
persone di quelle che c'erano in classe
e non solo la comunicazione ad oggi è
una delle parti se non la parte più
importante del mio lavoro che consiste
nel comunicare idee o aiutare gli altri
a comunicare le proprie idee ad un
pubblico sotto forma di video Ma come è
possibile che un ragazzino che spesso e
volentieri non spiccicava una singola
parola per ore e ore di lezioni Sei
arrivato a fare un qualcosa in cui
l'obiettivo principale è proprio il
comunicare Beh sicuramente il fatto di
farlo sotto forma di video aiutato in
quanto va ad eliminare quel fattore
sociale che ci limita dall'esprimere
liberamente le nostre idee
magari dietro quella videocamera ci sono
centinaia di migliaia di persone ma
tutto ciò che noi vediamo È un obiettivo
è un microfono che personalmente mi
intimidivano molto di meno rispetto a
non essere umano Ma non è sempre stato
così
per quanto io abbia iniziato a fare
video sin da piccolo C'è voluto un po'
prima che diventassi io stesso il centro
dell'attenzione
o addirittura Prima che arrivassi a
rendere pubblici tali video e la parola
a cui ho sempre attribuito la colpa di
tutto ciò e timidezza non basterebbero
le dita di tutte le vostre mani per
contare quante volte questo aggettivo mi
sia stato attribuito dagli altri ed è
proprio come risultato del sentirmelo
dire costantemente che non solo sono
arrivato a crederci ma ne ho fatto parte
integrante della mia vita era
praticamente diventato il mio secondo
nome
Poi però è successo un qualcosa che ha
cambiato radicalmente il corso degli
eventi e no non è quel taglio di capelli
a dir poco imbarazzante al 16 anni
decise di fare tre mesi di vita in
Canada Cioè non è che lo decisi
semplicemente portai la brochurdi
Intercultura ai miei genitori e furono
loro a fare due più due quindi da un
lato è merito loro se arrivai a prendere
una decisione Così estrema e dall'altro
non mi dispiace mai l'idea di saltare
tre mesi di liceo classico così andai
quindi in un paesino di 8.000 abitanti
sperdute in Ontario dove il massimo del
divertimento consisteva in una piazzola
con un paio di fast food è un bowling
piuttosto antiquato e dopo un po' di
giorni settimane di immersione in un
ambiente dove io non conoscevo nessuno e
nessuno conosceva me realizza qualcosa
capii che ognuno di noi alla nascita non
è altro che un foglio bianco e crescendo
andando avanti con gli anni non facciamo
altro che riempire questo foglio di
aggettivi abitudini di fare che col
tempo diventano sempre più parte di noi
il fatto però è che noi non siamo gli
unici a scrivere su questo foglio anzi
spesso e volentieri lo fanno gli altri
per noi
soprattutto quando siamo giovani
più nello specifico però mi accorsi che
iniziare da zero e cancellare
interamente questo foglio non era poi
così difficile quanto pensassi
soprattutto se vai dall'altra parte del
mondo dove nessuno ti Calcola ne sta
perlomeno pronunciare il tuo nome
correttamente
Quindi ho fatto quello che dentro di me
ho sempre voluto fare sono cambiato ho
iniziato da zero e ho cancellato quel
famoso foglio bianco e ho capito che
questa cosa avrei potuto farlo ovunque
anche a casa dove quel foglio era così
pieno di aggettivi che mi stavano
stretti da non esserci più spazio per
scrivere nulla e in parte Lo feci quando
tornai a casa Ero effettivamente una
persona diversa ora non dico che è tutta
un tratto la mia intro versione la mia
timidezza erano scomparse Però col tempo
inizia a prendere delle decisioni che
erano sempre più lontane dalla
percezione che gli altri avevano di me
cominciai a fare video su Tik Tok a
conoscere sempre più persone nel mondo
dei social e arrivai a 18 anni a
prendere una scelta che probabilmente
nessuno si sarebbe mai aspettato da me
ovvero non continuare gli studi ma presi
un bel volo solo andata per Milano con
pochi soldi pochi contatti Ma un'idea
ben precisa di quello che avrei voluto
fare ovvero rendere la creazione di
video il mio lavoro
la sensazione che provavo dentro di me
in quel momento era la stessa identica
che provai prima di partire per il
Canada e se quella prima esperienza
aveva portato a così tanti risultati
positivi non poteva essere una semplice
coincidenza doveva esserci una
connessione
e infatti c'era nel giro di pochi giorni
arriva a lavorare per quelle stesse
persone che magari pochi anni prima
idolatravo consideravo dei modelli di
vita ancora una volta
l’iniziare da zero il cambiare ambiente
è cancellare interamente quel famoso
foglio bianco mi aveva portato in una
situazione che è giusto la settimana
prima avrei considerato impensabile non
era più una semplice coincidenza
Katy che quella timidezza che aveva da
sempre contraddistinto la mia vita
poteva tranquillamente essere messa in
stand by nessuno nasce timido Se lo
diventiamo spesso a causa di esperienze
negative in ambito sociale che proviamo
nel corso della nostra crescita e la
paura costante di essere giudicati e di
dire la cosa sbagliata nel momento
sbagliato è qualcosa che acquisiamo e
amplifichiamo sempre di più col passare
del tempo e innegabile che sia per
chiunque uno dei più grandi ostacoli nel
raggiungimento dei propri sogni e dei
propri obiettivi
Fortunatamente però andare dall'altra
parte del mondo e cambiare cambiare
completamente luogo e persone attorno a
sé non è l'unica soluzione per
sconfiggere la timidezza ho trovato che
ci sono Infatti ben tre metodi che
chiunque può applicare indipendentemente
dal luogo o dalla situazione in cui si
trova numero uno
noi siamo la media delle cinque persone
che frequentiamo di più e circondarsi di
persone che siano l'esatto opposto
rispetto a noi può aiutarci tantissimo
nell'uscire dalla nostra zona di comfort
per esempio se io ho 16 anni non avesse
avuto la spinta esterna dei miei
genitori e dei miei amici probabilmente
non sarei mai partito per il Canada e
magari non mi troverei neanche qui oggi
numero 2
Lancia lo zaino dall'altra parte della
recinzione così tutto ciò che potrei
fare Sarà andare a recuperarlo
Lasciatemi spiegare Quando a 18 anni
acquistai Quel volo solo andata per
Milano la mia testa pullulava di dubbi
incertezze e voglia di tirarsi indietro
ma il semplice fatto di acquistare un
volo Anche solo fare una promessa a
qualcuno ti va ad affidare un peso una
responsabilità
e dall'essere una lotta interna alla
nostra mente dove la timidezza non
avrebbe alcuna difficoltà a mettere KO
l'istinto e la ragione diventa una lotta
esterna fidatevi sarà molto più
difficile dire di no e non scavalcare la
famosa recensione una volta che avremo
esternato le nostre intenzioni perché
noi come esseri umani abbiamo una paura
matta di quello che gli altri pensano di
noi è sicuramente non ci piacerebbe
essere visti come dei codardi privi di
coraggio o sbaglio numero 3
stesso lo so probabilmente questa frase
la sentirete decine e decine di volte
oggi ma se è così c'è un motivo se noi
siamo timidi in principio E perché
abbiamo paura di non essere accettati
abbiamo paura di non essere all'altezza
della situazione per questo bisogna
ricordarsi ogni tanto che ognuno di noi
è unico davvero non esiste nessuna in
questa sala il cui foglio di cui
parlavamo prima sia lo stesso identico a
quello di qualcun altro ognuno di noi ha
qualcosa di speciale da offrire al
prossimo magari quello che tu consideri
banale Ovvio Per qualcun altro potrebbe
essere la più grande scoperta dell'anno
quindi non cercate di essere qualcun
altro siate voi stesse e siate
orgogliosi di chi siete voglio
concludere con una riflessione una
riflessione che mi ha aiutato e continua
ad aiutarmi tantissimo nei momenti di
incertezza o di dubbio
quando tornai dal Canada inizia a
comportarmi in modo insolito agli occhi
degli altri capi che tutto ciò di cui la
nostra mente ha bisogno per uscire dai
classici schemi e andare controcorrente
e un pretesto quello del Canada nella
mia mente non era altro che un pretesto
una giustificazione per compiere delle
azioni che magari al tempo consideravo
estreme e sono sicuro al 100% che
sarebbe successa la stessa identica cosa
anche con un'altra destinazione o magari
con una scelta che c'entra poco e nulla
con un'esperienza All'estero ma che a
livello mentale si può tranquillamente
paragonare alla prima
non solo il pretesto iniziale non è
altro che la goccia che fa traboccare il
vaso da lì in poi saremo noi stessi
inconsapevolmente auto giustificare le
scelte prese Pensate un ragazzino che
non ha mai copiato durante le verifiche
in classe ma che trovatosi in una
situazione di difficoltà o stress arriva
a farlo per la prima volta
vi assicuro che come conseguenza
naturale di questa azione quel ragazzino
arriverà pensare che alla fine copiare
non è poi così cattiva come cosa sia
chiaro Non è un invito a copiare durante
le verifiche Ma è una chiara
dimostrazione del fatto che basta
pochissimo per prendere una scelta noi
inusuale e una volta fatto è tutta in
discesa
Quindi se c'è qualcosa che vorrei
chiedervi oggi e di usare questo
discorso come un pretesto un pretesto
per compiere una singola azione anche
piccola che però prima d'ora non avreste
mai fatto ma che in fondo in fondo avete
sempre desiderato se qualcuno vi dovesse
chiedere il perché delle vostre azioni
date tranquillamente la colpa a me e
sarei onorato Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]